la participación indígena un tercer
candidato indígena y una fuerza indígena
capaz de paralizar el país como lo vimos
en años anteriores como influye en esta
elección el pueblo indígena ecuatoriano
que tiene un alto porcentaje poblacional
bueno yo creo que influye mucho si bien
en un yahoo pérez no se puede considerar
como un dirigente histórico del
movimiento indígena así que en los
últimos 15 años he configurado o se ha
posicionado sobre todo aquí en el sur en
el austro ecuatoriano como un dirigente
sobre todo la llegada de 4 nariño que es
una de las opciones organizaciones
adscritas a la conaie en más que el
movimiento indígena yo que es suele
actuar digamos de manera cohesionada y
muy disciplinada y con apoyos el ya
cooper es creo que capitaliza una serie
de demandas insatisfechas es que la
mayor parte de candidaturas presentes
para la elección presidencial no tomaron
para sí después de las protestas de
octubre de 2019 no en nada en octubre de
2019 vimos un movimiento indígena
refortalecido que de alguna manera había
sido aplicado durante los 10 años de
gobierno de rafael
había sido perseguido sus líderes
enjuiciados
vimos ese resurgir y la capacidad
organizativa que tiene el movimiento
indígena en el país y también la
capacidad que tiene el movimiento
indígena de plegar o de digamos o de
aunar otra serie de demandas porque en
octubre había muchos doctores habían
muchas demandas y de alguna manera
la candidatura de jacko pérez y la
defensa por el agua y toda la retórica y
el discurso construido en torno a su
nombre y el nombre de su programa de
gobierno no nunca por la vida y demás yo
creo que viene a visibilizar también una
parte importante de los electores que
están buscando otra cosa que no es
corregir lo que no es la derecha y que
claro son los partidos políticos